andy dalton guy who will be supplanted
at some point
presumably by justin fields dalton's got
that one-year eight-figure contract he
comes in at number 29
on the chris sims quarterback top 40
countdown
how long do you think it will be and
it's funny i'm looking this and it says
how long until andy is wearing a hat and
earpiece i thought it said hat and
hairpiece
uh and uh that's a very different uh
connotation altogether but how long
until he's on the
on the bench watching justin fields well
he i mean he's gonna have to fight him
off i mean it's it's this
this is gonna be the pressure is gonna
be on him every day i mean yeah
you know mac jones is gonna put pressure
on on cam newton i do believe that
but yes you know andy dalton is gonna
have to answer the bell and be
on his game daily with justin fields the
number 11
pick we traded up to get him and do all
those things
and that's what i'll say about andy
dalton first off he's got more physical
ability than we all give him credit for
moves a little bit better than we want
to give him credit for
arm has a little bit more power than we
want to give it credit for
he can push the ball down the field
outside the numbers do all those type of
things
he can move out of the pocket a little
bit but
it's not enough to none of it's enough
for you to just go
man he's our guy he's the future here we
go
he's one of those talents in the nfl
where you go oh yeah he could start for
us
but i think we could do better he is one
of those guys and i i don't
like to say that and or be disrespectful
in any in any way about that he's had a
great career
he still can do some good things but i i
think it's going to be
him having to play at a high level
through training camp and preseason
and justin fields i think would have to
be play poor or do bad
to not even be in the mix mike i i think
in my heart of hearts mike
if if i'm the bears and you you hear me
out here if you think i'm right or
anything
i have a package for justin fields in
week one uh
when we go to play the rams okay we go
down and score a touchdown
all right we get the ball back andy
dalton the offense they go three and out
oh it's series number three
let's bring justin fields in we got a
few quarterback design runs the rams
haven't been able to prepare for this
they don't know what they're gonna do
oh we got a nice easy game plan pass off
of those runs
okay we got justin fields on the play
for six or seven plays in this
you know this series see where it goes
maybe if you go score points maybe you
keep him in i don't know
but i would think you have a package
ready to kind of slowly get him
indoctrinated in uh early on in the year
something i heard over the weekend that
made a lot of sense
now this sets aside the fact that matt
nagy the coach and ryan pace the gm
won't
fully and completely be judged on fields
until 2022
right maybe there is some reason to go
easy with him
matt nagy fully aware of the patrick
mahomes
career arc which consisted of what in
2017
right not playing until the final game
of the season
a meaningless game where they played the
broncos and he he wasn't
spectacular but he was good he wasn't
anybody but he was good enough to get to
say all right he's ready he's ready
right but um maggie who then became the
bears coach
after that season remembering that
experience remembering that value of
having
patrick mahomes sit there could be an
inclination chris
to have justin field sit most if not all
of the year
and be ready to go come 2022. i i hear
you i do
i i don't favor that formula i don't
one i don't think the bears are in the
same place as the chiefs
so i think you know you might you might
need justin fields to grow more than
maybe a patrick mahomes
if that made any sense really but
the other aspect like that that would
jump
out or at least that i'll play devil's
advocate because of course we know that
worked out great
but i'm still more of a guy that put him
out there get him to play
who i i know mahomes had that great
first year after sitting out
you know in his rookie years so now it's
his second year who's to say that year
wouldn't have been better though if he
played his rookie year that's where i
think sometimes people just gloss that
over and go well
patrick mahomes set out his first year
in the second year look what he did
who's to say he wouldn't have thrown for
62 touchdowns and maybe not been fooled
by new england in the first half of the
afc championship game
when they were playing some crazy
defense maybe that experience would have
helped
him play better in the first half of
that game where they scored no points or
anything like that
that's all i'm saying i i you know i'm
not to say i'm right or wrong but i just
think it's good food for thought
nonetheless
i remember travis kelsey being on this
show 2017
season we asked about patrick mahomes
and he was talking about the incredible
things he was doing on the practice
field and then the chiefs
fell into a funk offensively and we were
saying put him
yeah go ahead put mahomes on the field
they resisted for whatever reason but
hey they could have been
in four straight afc championships who
knows not three straight if they had
gone with mahomes
so just because it's worked the last
three years for the chiefs doesn't mean
it wouldn't have worked
in 2017 and it is different too andy
dalton isn't a guy
who has equity built up with the bears
that's right they brought in and paid 10
million bucks to and they called him the
starter
and they they put qb1 on twitter and uh
he may be qb2 before too long here's
jay cutler former qb one of the chicago
bears appearing on espn
1000 in chicago with his views on
whether or not
justin fields should play or sit
i wouldn't play the kid to start like
that's what i would that would
that's where i would start i would let
him watch and i think it's just a tough
spot
to put you know someone out there
especially in chicago and
you know i think andy is is more than
serviceable i think they can win games
with andy and
kind of float the ship along until he's
right the kid's ready
yeah and look if dalton comes out of the
gates and plays well
then then let it ride and this is
different than jimmy garoppolo
garoppolo comes out of the gates and
plays well you let it ride you let it
ride all season long then you got a
problem next season
andy dalton would have to do a hell of a
lot to throw a wrench
into the plan for justin fields to be
the guy come 2022.
i don't think dalton is going to be
capable and even if the bears would be
really good
no one's going to think dalton's the one
who came in and did it
so i don't think they have that danger
if they do let justin field sit
yeah i'm just a firm believer if you're
going to trade up
if you're going to give up a future
first round pick and package it with
this year's first round pick
and trade up to get a guy a quarterback
in round one
fringe of the top 10 you better be ready
to use him and i can't come up with a
good reason not to use no i mean listen
andy dalton they can win they certainly
do those things but i'm like you you're
right you make those type of moves
from all appearances it looks like 22 20
22 is the year
right i want to have them ready i don't
want it to be like
whoa this is the big year my ass is on
fire we might get fired
hey let's throw our quarterback out here
and let's see how he grows during the
year no i already wanted like some
growth already there
and here's another aspect to where again
i know they can win and do things with
andy uh
andy dalton and we're supposed to be
talking about him but
this is a bear's conversation either way
they you know yeah right to this point
matt nagy's offense has not shown us
like
that it's gonna be anything special
we've seen nothing to think
schematically
that there's something there with a guy
like andy dalton that it's just gonna
pop and here we go like whoa all right
awesome
i i it has a chance to be more special
with me
with a guy like justin fields he's gonna
give you more schematical advantages in
his skill set and what he can do
and maybe expand what i would call a
pretty ordinary offense
and give it a little bit more complexity
and things to think about
when you got a guy like justin fields
who we know can run the way he can run
and even though he needs polish in his
passing
has a stronger arm than andy dalton i
mean he'll be able to launch 65 and 70
yard bombs
to stress the defense out that way too
so that's where i get into
some of the advantages of justin fields
like i hear what jay cutler's saying
but man this guy played at ohio state
he's been in the national championship
game he went to georgia before that
i i don't think the pressure's going to
be too much for him
you know i think it's one of those
things that if he shows he's kind of
like ready
grasping the offense doing good in
pre-season and training camp like you
and i have discussed
that you slowly get them ready early in
the year and when you
you think the timing's right you get
them in there and you go
i just don't understand the disconnect
that we see where a team demonstrates
on draft day how thoroughly it believes
in a guy
and then acts differently after that
yeah i know
in in this day and age that doesn't work
anymore and yes the chiefs got away with
it but
for the most part just like the 49ers
it's one of the reasons why we're so
confused about what they did
yeah all that you give up and now you're
still talking about jimmy gb in your
quarterback
there's there's something there there's
a there's a split there that i think a
lot of fans and a lot of media look at
and say
we don't get it hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports